[Music]
thank you
[Music]
your waking world is shaped
by dreams
dreams and nightmares that I create
[Music]
I must control
he's out there looking for me isn't he
can you imagine the damage he could do
your hope
and so will Humanity without dreams for
a while I haven't had a decent night
sleep in ages
I'm not gonna stop
until they've reshaped this world
tell us what power of dreams
[Applause]
I thought about giving up but I have a
job to do it and I do it things have
changed
your eyes were telling me everything
every thought every feeling
[Music]
my Creations do not walk amongst the
living killing Mortals for pleasure oh
you don't think dreams can die
that's fine now
thank you
nightmares do not belong in the waking
world
oh it turns out I fit right in
please don't die
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we are the ancient ones then they built
churches Cathedrals or potato breakfast
Stone Circle
you can make it better down here
gradually they abandoned us
old forgotten gods
now there are new Gods growing in
America
[Music]
and they want to destroy us was a coming
Shadow I have a big role for you
[Music]
time to ride
foreign
[Applause]
did that happen
there's something special going on here
and I feel a part of it
he is dangerous I need you to believe
that there's always a cast with him just
hadn't paid it yet
the heart begins I'm going to take him
out no you take them all out
this is America
Greatest Story Ever Told
are we ready
I am
[Music]
[Music]
I am an angel
[Music]
you are a demon
we're hereditary enemies
get thee behind me foul fiend
after you
armageddon's days away and we 've lost
the Antichrist
we have to work together
we have nothing whatsoever in common I
don't even like you you do
foreign
[Music]
death
who exactly summons them
not my department
[Music]
the end of the world starts here
you don't get tornadoes in England we do
it today
[Music]
I lie to you you're a demon that's what
you do
we're doomed
welcome to the end times
it's nice and hanging we can't give up
now
stop the wall
that doesn't have to be a more
of course there does otherwise how would
we win it
stand
s
ourselves
last great battle between head and
health
to the world
to the world
[Music]
I've heard Tales of your kind Witcher
you're a mutant
created by Magic
roaming the continent
we don't want your kind here hunting
monsters
I thought you'd have fangs or horns or
something
I had them filed down
people call you a monster too
[Music]
why not kill them because then I am what
they say I have all of our choices draw
our Destinies closer
reviews
don't judge me they say witches can't
feel human emotion
what do you believe
[Music]
greater
middling
it's all the same
princess cirilla is your destiny
actor
if you dismiss it yes
you will unleash
true Calamity upon us all
don't take that chance
[Music]
don't beep
should be just fine without me
I'm not good I've been throwing myself
into work
and going out with you
at least you guys got to say goodbye as
far as I'm concerned Lucifer can well he
can go to hell
we don't need them
[Music]
hello bad guys
[Music]
you're here yes I got a bit bored so I
thought I'd pop back up
the first acting different down there
time is different I was in hell for
thousands of years a few things might
have changed Lucifer 2.0 we're back
great
how could you go home without me I'm not
Lucifer
Lucifer told me he had a twin brother
nice to meet you
I'm Michael
I am not gonna break Lucifer's life I'm
gonna take him
stronger than you think
what do you truly desire
welcome home how do you like the mess I
made
[Music]
for now I'm going to stick to police
work and avoid anything God related
hilarious
I love this city and I see it going to
hell
sometimes I think this place is cursed
but I won't let it fall apart without a
fight
citizens of Gotham we will not we cannot
let these killers and these robbers and
these rapists and these thugs with not
on my watch
there's a war coming
a terrible War
[Music]
the chaos rivers of blood in the streets
I know it
it's my new partner Jim Gordon you have
a little danger in your eye I wonder
to do with that
who killed people before
that was war This Is War we're at War
[Music]
what's your name my name's Bruce Wayne
I promise you
I will find the man who did this
I'm learning to conquer fear fear
doesn't need conquering fear tells you
where the edge is
somebody has to take over it might as
well be me gossip is on a knife edge
this is not a city for nice guys
[Music]
however dark and scary the world might
be right now there will be light there
will be light rocks
[Music]
loser Diego
you're right
what the hell did we do now
what was that the end of the world
November 25th 1963. and where am I now
that was 10 days earlier I need to find
my family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
first off I want to say we brought the
end of the world back here with us oh my
God again my cult is gonna be so pissed
I told him we had until 2019 we have
until Monday
we know something changes the timeline
to make it right again
before everyone and everything we know
is dead
[Music]
who are those guys they're not here to
sell vacuums the commission will hunt us
down wherever and whenever we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are an open book written for very
dumb children
class spin here no unfortunately ghosts
can't time travel are you kidding me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
quick rundown Luther super strength
class can communion with the dead
Allison can rumor anyone to do anything
except she never uses it
I heard a rumor you punched yourself in
the face
[Music]
you know
he started asking questions I gotta find
that Mama take this
this shot for me what was he hunting I
begged you quit as you can see me you
don't want to know
we got work to do
[Music]
you're my brother I die for you
I'm an angel of the lord we have work
for you
Mama put my guns in the ground I should
send you straight back to hell oh sure
we're new Chippendales dancers we just
moved in Next Door Animal Control FBI
there's so much evil I feel like I could
drown in it hello dance
YouTube sack up and help me for once
Bobby all you gotta do is ask we're the
guys who saved the world
I do believe in us I believe in all of
us
and I'll keep believing until I can
[Applause]
be fighting losing people we love this
isn't just a story it's our lives
[Applause]
I set out for the north some 12 months
ago and this is the first of the
discoveries I made
Myriad of Worlds of which the
magisterium controls only one
promised the magisterium control hasrael
there's a great change coming that will
threaten us all
I'm going to give you something what
does it do give her support to play in
all this and a major one tell me where
the elysiometer is I will destroy all of
this
we represent a number of families who
have lost children the
school
I think this can help
she can read the elysiometer she will be
more valuable to us than any Soldier we
have
no children back you may have a heart
and magisterium out of muscle
what else do we need to fight them
has anyone seen a bear
[Music]
it's a good beer we won't have any
trouble
witches have known of the other worlds
for thousands of years
asriel is bringing a great War
then I hope I'm strong enough
naira now is the time to chill Society
[Music]
why am I so important to her
once the world sees the possibilities
no more
abuse
no more Darkness
[Music]
want to take my
fate of more than this world
[Music]
my Celestial sister
hey vampire baby daddy
my heart
without them
without the gun
I'm nothing
[Music]
help
[Applause]
demons running amok mystical portals to
another worldly Realm
[Music]
debail
you glorious Ginger give me a big one
you listen to me
nobody with our family
game on vacation is over
I am gonna kick so much I might go up a
shoe size God I've missed you I really
are
whoa do not point that at anything
unless you want to go out now I do want
nachos let's go get our steps in we're
gonna name our little town at the demon
freeze on once and for all clear eyes
full bra can't lose okay Jon Snow in a b
cup together we take back the Purgatory
we heard so God
[Music]
like I said so good to be home
I'd say we're doing pretty great Dodge
is gone I haven't heard anything from
Eden things are finally kind of normal
[Music]
this is insane there's a time travel key
I broke down the barrier between our
world and the world far greater
and who's at that place that I've
learned
or something of honest
what's happening he's here
each key that I possess makes a part of
that
as well
[Music]
bad thoughts happening
I know what we need to do
you trust me of course I do
not knowing about magic
having that separate me from my kids
it was hard
[Music]
this is our house those keys belong to
us
is bad
this is really bad
thanks for the ride
[Music]